it is hard to imagine in summer what it
takes to survive -55 in winter here
near chersky in the russian arctic
but temperatures here are warming fast
twice to three times the global average
and as they do the permafrost or
permanently frozen soil not far below
ground
is thawing causing massive soil erosion
along the arctic shores and coastlines
and releasing powerful greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere
nikita zimov and his father sergey have
made it their life's work
to raise the alarm over thawing
permafrost when i was a kid
temperature of performance temperature
of ground is ground on average was
minus six centigrade now it's
minus three and even warmer and in the
warm years it's going almost close to
zero
and i think in the next few decades two
three decades at most
i think majority of peripherals here in
the arctic will start to degrade
it's already driven a rush in mammoth
tusk ivory
as soil erosion reveals the permafrost's
treasures
that's a big bone of some leg bone of
some
mammoth of a mammoth yeah how do you
know
the size so only mamas could have such
bone
rhinoceros it's a bit different they're
also big bones but this one is big
that's quite a
little part of one very big leg bone
but the permafrost also contains
hundreds of billions of tons of carbon
which is slowly being released
that's a pure ice 50 of this sediment
is not carbon it's ice and ice
is melting rapidly ice is mixing with
these sediments
and turn them into mud and all the slide
down
ice is causing ground depressions and
that's something that's
why the sperm frost is dangerous not
only about carbon
carbon which is 40 meters below who
cares it will
sell for millennials and millennials
millennials
ice will make it melt much much faster
to show you what the carbon consists of
we're inside a permafrost cave
they were used a lot for storage here in
the arctic especially
by fishermen these roots are essentially
plants that were frozen
in the soil at the time when the
mammoths were roaming the grasslands
up above but as this stuff thaws this
decomposes
and greenhouse gases are emitted into
the atmosphere
methane and co2 and that warms up the
planet
further the more permafrost degrades the
more buildings will end up looking like
this
the arctic's rusting soviet
infrastructure collapsing
as the ground gives way expected to cost
russia
50 billion pounds a quarter of the
federal budget
by 2050 yes
for a long time sergey zimov was a lone
voice on the dangers of permafrost thor
and the methane he noticed daily
bubbling up from below ground
missing growth so fast last year
it was most fast growth in all history
i feel it's because our permafrost start
to melt
and any point now produced me saying
and we have millions spot like this
around my house the zemos have a
solution
return the arctic to how it was during
the mammoth era
bring back the millions of animals which
used to roam here
to scrape away and trample down the
insulating layer of snow when they
forage for food
which counterintuitively traps in the
heat
and stops the cold from penetrating
it seems fanciful not least because of
the scale that it would require
yes you know crazy scientists from
russia want to bring what
millions of animals yeah yeah
telemedicine but if you have better
solution
give me one as we travel back a distant
arctic
wildfire turns the sun the color of mars
and lends a haze to the horizon
these fires now raging through siberia
send
more carbon into the atmosphere and warm
the permafrost further a vicious
feedback loop
which compounds the crisis in our
climate
dynamic sky news in the russian arctic